welcome to chat gbt at home a chat gbt
like app written entirely by chatgpt I
mostly filmed this back in December but
then my wife Stephanie and I had twins
and honestly I've just been lucky if I
can just get a shower in for the day but
I've been working on getting much more
efficient at caring for them and
multitasking so here I am with this
video finally one of the main things
that I wanted to show here is just how
powerful chat GPT is compared to even
something like copilot for the task of
software development both of these
models are technologically very similar
models and yet chat GPT offers what
appears to be a massive Leap Forward in
functionality
by way of actual scope limitation of all
things
I wanted to come up with a fairly
Advanced example of a piece of software
that would be impossible to reliably
create with copilot but would show off
why chat GPT and a chat bot sort of
scope for a generative model is so
powerful so getting things started
chatgpt has come up with a sort of
outline for how things will work but no
code yet so we can just simply begin
asking for code at first we just get
some snippet examples about like how
this might work in a really basic way
but it's not really an altogether script
that we can just immediately use again
though we can just ask for that copy the
code paste it into an editor and run it
and here we hit our first of many snags
but this is where chat GPT starts to
shine over a purely generative model
like copilot we can copy and paste this
error and chatgpt suggests some ideas
for us to fix it in this case I opt to
just change the port for the app re-run
it and here we have our basic website
all we have here so far though is really
just a basic flask app demo there's
certainly nothing impressive yet here so
let's ask chat gbt to start integrating
a large language model and chatbot
structure again initially chat gbt just
kind of shows us some Snippets to get
this done which could be useful if
you're already a developer but we're
trying to do literally no work here so
let's instead ask for the full script up
to this point and there we have it
throughout this video there's a lot of
me requesting things like the full
script I'm not going to show it every
single time but just know it's as simple
as this to to get what you want next
we'll run things the language model is
downloading from hugging face things are
looking pretty good like we're making
maybe some progress but now we're
hitting yet again another error again
the power of chat gbt is we can just
copy and paste this error we don't even
have to further describe it most of the
time you just copy and paste the error
copy and paste the change suggested try
again another day another error another
copy and paste of the error and another
answer that tries to teach us what the
problem might be but we really just want
that code so we'll just ask for that
throw in a request for the HTML template
while we're at it and boom
I also had been getting annoyed at
needing to go to like slash chatbot
instead of just going to the home page
so I'm also requesting chat GPT changes
the URL path to the chat page to just be
at that index so I don't have to keep
doing that either from here we get the
code for the python file and HTML I
already know where this HTML template
should go but just for fun I ask chatgpt
where to put it alternatively I am
pretty confident if we just put it like
in the directory that we're working in
and then ran it we would get an error
and we could just report that error to
chat GPT and chat GPT would almost
certainly fix the problem for us and
tell us well we need to put the template
where we need to put it either way even
really simple basic stuff like this like
showing us that outline I think it's
just really interesting just how useful
chat GPT can be even just for stuff like
this making it just extremely clear
where the template should go with the
sort of directory outline but of course
we hit yet another error and again I
report this error to chat GPT and we go
back and forth for a bit once we're at a
point where I think maybe chat GPT knows
what's right to do again I just ask for
the full script then finally Moment of
Truth and it's another error
this happens a lot here and I'm just
going to save you the annoyance of the
back and forth and all of that but it
really was just constantly copying and
pasting errors and copying and pasting
the suggested code to fix it
so then finally we have traction and
things are starting to work we at least
have a generation that said this
generation does look a little weird
while the logic isn't quite yet here to
make this language model a chat bot the
generation really should be fairly
coherent at least and it's not to fight
this I begin describing the issue to
chat GPT this was probably the hardest
spot in the entire exercise because I
was really just doing my best to act
like I didn't know anything about
anything going on here like as if I was
somebody who just didn't know anything
about large language models or
programming or anything like that
eventually we get through it but I did
have to suggest that maybe there was
something going wrong with the tokenizer
but that's literally all I said I just
said hey I think something might be
wrong with the tokenizer and finally we
do start to get some coherent results so
it's not formatted how I would like just
yet it's purely generating a
continuation but that is indeed all
large language models do without any
further in production in order to be a
chatbot like chat GPT all you need to do
is suggest to the language model that
what it should continue producing is a
chatbot dialogue or a chat log we can do
this with a pre-prompt so our text input
field on our website is our prompt to
the model but we can actually use this
text input to build on top of a starting
prompt that we set in the python logic
in the back end that already gets the
ball rolling for this sort of chat bot
dialog and that is the secret the magic
of making a large language model behave
like a chatbot this is probably very
similar to what chat GPT is doing it
just has a pre-prompt that coaxes it
into being a chatbot and then there is
some logic that's kind of splits it
apart and makes it appear like it's a
chat dialogue to you the user in the UI
but there's really nothing more fancy
about it is just fooling the large
language model into continuing this sort
of dialogue from here I just start
tackling each problem one by one often I
found it useful to just kind of reset by
telling chat GPT hey here's my current
code I describe whatever the current
issue was that you know was going wrong
and then what I really wanted to happen
after some further back and forth I am
starting to make some real progress as
you can see we need to probably stop the
generation once it's done with the Bots
response again these are generative
models so it's going to just keep
generating until it hits some sort of
stop token and what this often can mean
is it's actually going to continue
generating its own new human input
there's nothing that tells this this
large language model that hey you got to
stop when you know after you generate
the Bots response don't keep generating
the human response all it wants to do is
just keep generating responses so that's
what it's going to do and it's most
likely to just go ahead and start
generating a human response and then
maybe another bot response or even as we
can see here where it adds an actual
other input entirely called robots
so from here speeding things up quite a
bit for a moment I worked to clip the
final generation to stop once the bot
response generation is done and then I
start working on keeping a history of
the chat ongoing I also found this step
to take quite a bit of time for chat GPT
to finally figure out it was a lot of
back and forth and trial and error like
making sure the history was still there
keeping it in the session all that said
the part that took the longest here was
actually just the chat GPT arbitrary
delay in text output in reality once a
sequence is chosen the full sequence is
actually already known and it could be
output immediately what this means is
once you see that chat GPT starts to
display text the full output that it's
going to show you is actually already
known they're just slowing things down
for you I think openai just does this
with chat gbt to slow big queries down
and to reduce overall system load on
what is otherwise a totally free
application so if chat gbt wasn't
limited in this way this problem would
have been resolved much faster and the
entire project would have taken probably
less than an hour total to build which
would be faster than I could probably
have done it myself because even as a
developer myself there is no way I could
just sit down and write this application
without any errors so you're still going
to have this like back and forth when
you get errors or things aren't working
in the way that you you expected them to
work you're still going to do the
debugging it's just here chat gbt is
doing the debugging and each time chat
GPT thinks about you know what might be
going wrong and propose the solutions
we're like just waiting on this like
arbitrarily slowed down uh generation
and that doesn't have to be the case so
this could be way faster and actually
way more powerful uh if that just wasn't
there so if there is some sort of
Premium chat GPT in the future I would
hope that this kind of arbitrary
slowdown would would be gone and again
at any point where I felt like chat GPT
was going in circles or maybe just
needed a reset sort of I would just copy
and paste my full code explain what the
latest issue was that I was having and
this would usually resolve the problem
after this process of just reporting
issues and getting new code to try we
finally have reached a point where we
have a chat history that is working it's
not a great history at this point but
we're still just doing r d uh and we're
also starting with a very small model
and a probably not great pre-prompt yet
but also this is chat GPT at home and
not actually chat GPT
so we are using that 125 million
parameter model as opposed to like gpt3
for example is 175 billion with a B uh
parameters so these are very very
different models I will show an example
at the end with a larger model in the
back end but this is also what's
actually kind of cool about an app like
the one I'm building here this is an app
I actually want we can we can swap in
and out different language models in the
back end because we're using that
hugging phase Transformers Library we
can just change the language model
that's running in the back end and so
you can run any of a whole host of
different models so depending on the
type of Machinery that you're running
things on or the quality I guess of the
chat bot that you want you can easily
swap in and out things anyway at this
point things are functioning as expected
from what I can tell and I do ask to add
a reset button so I don't have to like
start the app over and reload that model
into memory and all that
um and also so I don't have to like
refresh the page and all that even this
tiny request of just a reset button is
actually somewhat challenging because
this means not just adding a reset
button in HTML but it's adding the
Callback to actually do it and reset
that chat history and clear that
variable in the session and so on of
course we do still hit some small snags
on the way too so we just report those
snacks copy pasta with chat GPT suggests
and we finally wind up with a
functioning reset button at this point
the hard part honestly is is done the
actual logic and hard part of tying
everything together is done and now we
just need to kind of clean things up a
bit first we'll address the stopping
generation output after the Bots
response Chachi BT makes pretty quick
work of this problem and through some
testing it does look like it does
finally work
we're getting so close to being complete
here but then with some further testing
I happen to catch that there's also
instances of a lowercase human colon and
that's getting generated and and we need
to handle for that as well while
handling for that lowercase issue I
noticed that chat GPT really has just
solved this by lowercasing everything
again we need to find a different
solution after expressing this issue to
chat gbt the problem is solved after all
this it's time to make things look a
little better so I pass along my current
HTML code and ask chat gbt to help me
style it
okay this is at least a little better
but it's still not great yet so we'll
start tackling issues starting with the
reset button section that's going on
with a reset button in a button anyway
great that's done next I'll try to
address the overall kind of layout but
the result winds up being a little goofy
the padding issue is fixed but I don't
really want this side-by-side solution I
suppose in some ways this could be kind
of a cool uh structure but that's not
what I was going for so I asked chat gbt
to stack these elements vertically and
again that seems to have worked out even
though this is just HTML and CSS I just
can't stress enough how
um
how kind of complicated this really is
linguistically to then translate it to
HTML code and actually achieve the
result that I was asking for in such a
simple way and and really all the steps
that have been taken so far
it really is I I struggle to recognize
how incredible this technology really is
that we're actually doing something like
this creating this app that while it is
kind of a basic simplistic-ish app it's
also a pretty complicated app that
requires multiple disciplines coming
together and just a general
understanding not only of human language
but also programming and tying all these
things together and it just really does
blow my mind
um anyways the final major stylistic
change that I'd like to make is to color
the bot and human messages differently
like different colored chat bubbles in
contrast to what I was just saying
interestingly this was actually somewhat
challenging to do for chat GPT it is
kind of comical what Chachi BT has a
hard time with versus what it just like
blows through easily so despite the as
being what seems like it should be a
simple task of coloring every other
message a different color since at least
right now for every human input you will
have a bot response output so we'll
always be one and one so every other
could be color there's so many ways that
this could get done despite the
Simplicity this actually took quite a
bit of back and forth to get working
again this would have been very fast if
I wasn't having to wait on that chat GPT
arbitrary sequence output that is just
like I think probably just JavaScript
that is just slowing it down this
wouldn't have been that long but this
did take quite a bit of time I think to
some extent this was due to me also
having an outdated Jinja but I still
would have expected chat gbt to maybe
solve this problem in another way once
it realizes it's run out of ideas for
Jinja template logic maybe use
JavaScript or something like that so
anyway we eventually did get this
resolved but this was pretty hard
because initially we do get those chat
bubbles but they're not differently
colored but after a while we do finally
overcome the issue as well as make our
way to what I would consider a minimal
viable product that is chat gbt at home
created with chap gbt or rather created
by chat gbt here's an example with the
125 million parameter model this is a
very very small model as you can see the
response time is quite fast and it feels
pretty darn good this model isn't even
going to be remotely comparable to chat
gbt but as you can see it's actually
somewhat decent
um all things considered this model
isn't going to be coding for you it's
not going to be doing anything like
what's shown in this video but like I
said before we can actually just swap
out the back end model now to something
much much larger so for example we can
check out the 66 billion parameter model
and here's where things get a little
tougher to run unfortunately I don't
have any a or h100 gpus just lying
around so I'm actually running this on
the Puget workstation with a terabyte of
ram it will get the job done it will
just be slow we would much prefer this
to be running on the GPU but I don't
have 250 plus gigs of memory on my gpus
I also took the liberty to have a little
more fun and actually asked chat GPT to
generate a chat log between a human and
a bot where the bot was a sassy bot and
I'm using that chat generation as the
pre-promptier the first response from
this 66 Bill parameter model takes
almost 25 minutes to complete that's
quite a difference from the 125 million
parameter model that felt very Snappy
almost instantaneous but this is often
the case that the very first inference
on a Model that you just loaded onto
either memory or your GPU it does tend
to take a lot longer so let's go ahead
and try another one so the second and
third responses are lightning fast at a
whopping two minutes I think we could
have a lot of fun with this model and I
would like to dig around a little more
but two minute inference time is a bit
brutal it's going to make r d quite hard
but I think it would be cool to find a
solid pre-prompt that
functions
closer to chat gpt's full capabilities
that said chat EBT also did have a sort
of reinforcement learning layer on top
as far as I understand that
reinforcement learning layer though was
more so meant for like touring Test
passing so just people seeing those
responses from the chatbot and either
thinking that they were human generated
or bot generated like what what
responses looked good or what what they
were actually looking for so I don't
think that the actual back end language
models need that much work and so it
would be interesting to see if someone
can come up with a good solid
pre-promptu I don't think anybody
actually knows I don't think open AI has
released what is the pre-prompt to chat
GPT but that could be very interesting
I'm also just curious like how long is
the pre-prompt like how much information
is in that pre-prompt before you get to
even start playing because also chat gbt
does seem to allow for a very a long
chat dialogue that it still seems to
remember the history of so I also don't
know if they're doing something
interesting in the back end where maybe
they're compressing that information
down so for example if you have a really
long dialogue with chat gbt it's
conceivable that you could actually use
chat gbt to take some dialogue and ask
it hey please compress this down to
maybe a paragraph and then it compresses
that down and then that's that goes into
the pre-prompt so it's possible they're
doing stuff like that and again with
this app there's no reason why we can't
do the exact same thing with this
application so
anyway I will upload everything to
GitHub if anybody wants to play around
more with this there are issues in the
script uh you can find them if you want
I'm not really I'm not too worried about
it being like in you know a perfect app
uh if anything I would encourage anyone
who wants to keep building on it if they
want especially if you continue building
on it with chat gbt I want to see how
far this can go because uh this is I
don't think this is it's done I think
that there's much more that chat GPT
could make of this so anyways I will put
a link in the description to the GitHub
for everything up to this point and
again you can just like show you can
show like the python code and or the
HTML code and just say here's my current
code here's what I want to do next
um and go from there so anyway I think a
lot of cool software can be made with
copilot but there's really nothing like
this and with copilot you really have to
have that starting prompt it has to be
perfect for what you're trying trying to
achieve and if it at any point it gets
lost or produces an error it's
impossible to overcome it with just
copilot you must have a programmer kind
of help overcome it and that's not I'm
not trying to knock co-pilot I I love
copilot I use it every day all the time
but it is very interesting to me again
that co-pilot I would say the scope of
copilot is much wider than the scope of
chat GPT chat GPT has been narrowed very
specifically to be a chatbot and yet
through that scope limitation it is very
interesting that the functionality has
just exploded for for chat GPT based on
that scope limitation it's it's curious
and I think the main reason why it's
such an explosion in performance is
ichach EPT is not perfect it says dumb
things it makes mistakes in software
but the fact that you can report what's
wrong and then it thinks about it and
changes uh accordingly and suggests a
different way of going about it that's
what makes chatty that's what makes all
the difference and that's why maybe for
uh you know playing a doctor or arguing
a legal case or something like that chat
gbt is probably not the greatest idea
because it will make mistakes but when
it comes to something like software
development
it's just unquestionably powerful that
you can make pretty Advanced software
with little to no understanding of of
what you're doing which is just that's
just it's just incredible if you're
interested in learning more about neural
networks and how they work then check
out
nnfs.io otherwise I will see you all in
another video